so I got it I guess I'm gonna start with
the most important thing up front which
is when did you sign your exclusive
Disney deal because oh yes and then
Little Mermaid and you know the pirate
like yeah you know right after Pirates
of the Caribbean they came to myself and
John DeLuca who's my producing partner
and partners as well and said we'd love
you to be part of this family
would you consider you know an overall
deal which was a very rare thing it's
actually a very rare thing these days
and John I loved our experience so much
working with them we felt so valued and
so trusted and so allowed to do our work
in a very protective way that we said
yes immediately immediately it's so nice
to have a home in this business you know
because you were kind of like traveling
gypsies like well that'll do that and
you're looking around like what's the
next but to have like a home and a place
to work from it with it's been great and
I will say on this film in particular
this is really the jewel I believe in
their crown and they could have been all
over us you know he mean but they were
the exact opposite they gave us such
carte blanche I think because of the
trust we've created with each other and
Sean Bailey and Alan horn Alan Bergman
Bob Iger they all really sort of said go
do this we know you have the tools to do
it and we know you believe in it and I
felt they believed in me and us
ultimately the editing process is a
final rewrite yes so what was it like in
the editing room on this movie maybe
what surprised you about what you had
and what did you need - a finesse these
are such fresh great questions thank you
for asking this you know the challenges
with me with musicals in this thing I
spend the most time with is getting into
a musical number and getting out of it
that's something that's so carefully
orchestrated for me because what when
musicals don't work is when you feel
those seems like somebody's speaking and
then all of a sudden they break into
song and it's either works or feels
embarrassing so I really worked to find
a very seamless way into a song so it
just feels like it's naturally coming
out of the
scene it should feel like a progression
like there's no other way to express
yourself except through song and so
that's something I spent a lot of time
with um where did you have any deleted
scenes you know what I had nothing
except for one tiny tiny little the DVD
guys were actually quite upset is that
there's nothing that but there's there's
one little tag it was after they left
Topsy's we did a fun little idea where
the the alley they go down closes up and
it was like it was never there but it
felt like too many endings to the scene
and that was the only thing was a little
tiny tag that maybe was about I don't
know 10 seconds long 15 seconds long
with nothing nothing
my last question for you I could not be
more excited for a Little Mermaid
live-action oh great and so I have to
ask you where are you at in that and
what is it like working or collaborating
a little bit with Lynne haven't started
that process yet with him because I'm
actually just in the beginning beginning
exploration phase of house is going to
work can it work how do you do it it's a
very complicated challenge because you
know it's an underwater musical
basically at least half of it is and and
it was an animated film so it has to
work as a live-action film so how does
that all work so it's something we're
spending a lot of time just exploring
right now
you